Hey guys, I am super excited today, because
I hadn't made such a cool,
multilingual video in a long time.
I have a very special guest today,
we spoke a bunch of languages
about a bunch of topics,
and there is a bonus at the end
of the video recording to watch
and the other interesting piece of news today
is that we haven't made just one video,
we have made TWO different videos,
one for my channel, one for his channel.
So if you like what you are going to hear and see
please go to the description box
and in the comments section,
and click on the link
and you will enjoy
another very cool,
multilingual video
Enjoy the show!
Hi guys, hi from sunny Rome,
here is Luca, from Luca Lampariello.com and
I am here with the legendary Stefano Suigo,
Stefano, how is it going today?
Stefano: I am good, what about you?
Luca: I am great, fantastic,
the weather is great,
couldn't be better!
For all those..for the few left in the world
who don't know Stefano Suigo, Stefano,
is (laughter) a fantastic polyglot,
he speaks a bunch of languages
How many languages do you speak, Stefano?
Stefano: Well, let's say 10+2
Luca: 10+2
Ok, I guess you speak 10 fluently
and 2 you are learning, right?
Stefano: Kind of, yes
Luca: And..Stefano and I been thinking of
making videos for a couple 'years
and we met a couple of times,
I think only 2 times at the Polyglot Gathering
and at some other language events,
we hit it off very well,
and I think it was about time to make a video
about some interesting stuff
and most of all about language learning,
but not only about language learning.
We have posted some stuff on FB and Instagram
and we have received a lot of questions
both on his channel and on my channel
and here we are going to talk about a few of them
in a few languages with a surprise at the end.
So, without further ado, let's get started and
let's address the very first question.
Ok?
Ok
Are you ready?
Stefano: Yeah I am!
And thank you for having me, it's just
a privilege to be with you here today
Luca: It is pleasure,
the pleasure is all mine.
So, let's get started, every question
is going to be in English
but then we are going to decide which
language we are going to speak in and reply...
The first question..Stefano you can reply first and then I'm gonna go later, OK?
So..speak from day 1 or wait?
I wanted to stress the fact that we
have condensed some questions
and we are going to thank each and
everyone of you at the end of the video personally
but we have condensed questions because
a lot of questions gravitate around the same topics
so we just made them short.
Speak from day 1 or wait?
So in other words, do you think it is a good idea to
when you first learn a language from scratch
to start from the very beginning or
you think you should wait until you get
the language in you and then speak?
What do you think?
Stefano you are going to reply,
if you want, in French [en français]
[in French] Stefano: In French, we're going
to speak French, first...
Hello!
So, well, for me, it depends a lot
on what you mean by "speak from day 1".
Isn't it?
If it's just about producing sounds,
imitating the pronunciation,
to do the best you can do,
then yes, that's something I do
right from the very first day,
when I start learning a new language,
because, for me, it is crucial
to learn the pronunciation from the get-go
and so I will start producing sounds,
trying to imitate native speakers,
I'll try to create, build,
some basic sentences,
and speak out loud,
read out loud as well
So, if speaking from day 1 means that,
yes, that's what I do
but that does not mean that I am going to
look for a language partner
or even an online tutor
from the very first day or week.
No, I do it only after a preliminary phase
of autonomous learning
which can be more or less long,
depending on the language
I mean the distance between
my native language,
or the other languages
that I already master,
and my new target language.
Depending on this,
it can last 1, 2,
even 3 months,
e.g. for Georgian
because Georgian is a very
different language
from all the ones I have learned so far
So...yes, the goal is to reach a level
which allows you to hold a real
communication, a real conversation
and not just "hi", "how's it going?"
and "thanks"
because that's not enough
to have a real conversation
and most of all,
it does not allow you
me to learn much
from this conversation
I have to be able to at least
learn something new,
understand my tutor's corrections for instance
and to give something
to my language partner as well
So I would say, in conclusion,
you have to indeed start from the beginning,
to produce the language
Because a language is oral production,
mostly, for me
but through speaking to oneself
Luca: Excellent, excellent...
Stefano: ...and on the other hand,
whether to start speaking to other people
depends on the distance between languages.
It can last up to 3, 4 months.
Luca: Can you give a concrete example
of what happened
as you were learning a specific language
that took you a long time
and another one that did not
as it was a relatively easy language?
Stefano: Well... I would say,
with French...
(laugh) French is a language that,
actually,
I have learned without ever studying it
so I have learned the core of the language without...
without waiting for long
before having my first conversations
I live here, in Bruxelles.
It is a francophone city.
And it is here, on the street,
that I have practically learned French
On the other hand, as I said, Georgian...
It is such a different
and complex language...
That I wanted to be sure to at least
understand the corrections
and the reason of these corrections
before launching myself
into a conversation
Otherwise, it would not
have made that much sense
to just say "hello" and "thanks"
Luca: Definitely, definitely,
Actually, I think it depends,
Personally, I think,
there is a variety of different
positions, opinions about what to do,
whether to speak from the get-go,
or wait,
Personally I think, in the end,
it depends,
If one observes children,
one could draw the conclusion
that you need to wait 2, 3, 4...5 years
But we're not children!
We already have a language,
and we might start speaking it
from the very beginning
I personally think it depends.
Germans have a funny answer.
They say "jein"
[ja=yes / nein=no]
It's neither "ok", nor "no".
I think it depends on the person.
I think we can refer to two
categories of factors
that are major,
and play an important role
The first one is an objective factor
As you said, there are languages,
whose distance
- Personally I like this
linguistic concept: distance
It's not that a language is
difficult or not
it is, that it takes more time
if a language is distant
from a linguistic point of view
Like, suppose I were italian,
- well, actually, I am -
as an Italian, going to Japan,
- you talk about "distance" -
for me, learning Japanese,
which is distant from Italian,
is just like going from Rome
to Japan
And going to Spain is not that...
It's right over here,
2 hours long by plane
1 hour if you go to Barcelona
from Rome
and the same goes
for the linguistic distance
Spanish and Italian
Italian and French
Italian and Portuguese
It's two languages
whose distance is mi...
- well, I wouldn't say minimal -
So, there is not that much
distance to cover
And thus, it takes less time
That is one objective factor.
But then, you have the individual learner.
That is, there are individuals
who have a lot of experience,
or less experience
it depends on the individual's experience,
on time,
on whether you're retired,
- then you have a lot of time
whereas other people have less time
It depends on motivation,
it depends on where you live
it depends on a bunch of factors,
that depend on the individual,
So I, personally, would say
if there is a person that
comes to me and say
"Luca, should I speak right away?"
I say, it depends,
it depends on you,
Sometimes it's good,
sometimes it's less useful
In my case,
when I, for instance,
started learning Portuguese,
in 2018
- sorry, in 2008*
Um... No, it was 2010, actually...
I can't remember...
No, 2008! 2008!
With Mandarin
Well, I waited for months and months
before speaking
I realized I could've spoken
from the get-go
I could have spoken after 3 months
I was doing Assimil,
very slowly,
But the truth is,
after just 2, 3 months,
I could speak it already
For Catalan is the same thing, I think.
If I were to begin Catalan,
some day soon,
I'm sure I would start,
not necessarily speaking it,
I would need 1 or 2 months,
But I think in that case,
it's an advantage to speak from the get-go
Because you already have
many languages in you
and the language isn't complicated, so...
It depends. For me, it depends.
There are factors that are, say, objective
and others subjective.
Luca: So... I wanted to add this.
Stefano: Yes, absolutely.
For me, the same example
would be Dutch
If I were to start Dutch,
probably, I...
I wouldn't wait for 3 months before
having my first conversations.
Luca: Exactly. Exactly.
Luca: For me, for instance, Dutch...
Stefano: on the first week or...
Luca: Dutch, personally,
I started to learn it in...1999
And I realized, after 3 months, I...
I wrote a letter
- because I met...a girl -
I write a letter for her.
And I realized after...
- Ya, it's always about chicks
["meufs", common slang for girls,
less vulgar than "chicks" and not derogatory]
I realized that after 3 months, I...
I could write in Dutch,
because it's very similar to German
even though Germans can't understand Dutch
while the Dutch can understand German.
Anyway, that's a different story...
So, that was the first question
I have the list of questions -
We have a second question , I am going
to say it in English and in Italian
It was asked originally in Italian
I'll say it in Italian first of all and then I'll translate it into English
[in Italian] Since you guys are both Italian,
I'd love to know
which common points do you have
when it comes to language learning
- you laugh already -
and which you find absolutely necessary -
the "Polyglot's Commandments"
so the question is, since you are both Italian,
I want to know
the most important features,
the most important things
you have to stick to, you have to abide by,
that a native Italian polyglot has to abide by
I think this goes for any polyglot
regardless of the origin.
And there's an insight question,
there's another question related to that.
Which is: I'd like to hear you talking Italian
about what polyglots believe to be
the most essential elements
for achieving verbal fluency.
This is a little bit more specific,
for verbal fluency.
We are gonna reply to both questions.
[in Italian] And, as I was saying earlier,
you can start Stefano
and then I will complete, ok?
Stefano: Of course, first of all,
how nice talking
with you in Italian, which is the language
that we've always been using since we met
actually, it is weird to use other languages
we've never spoken other languages
other than English maybe
By the way, answering the question
I believe that the first "commandment",
even if it is quite strange to talk
about commandments,
The first golden rule I think is not just
common to the two of us,
but to the majority of
polyglots and language lovers,
is motivation.
Maybe the most important factor
is the motivation
and knowing why we are studying
a certain language
I think that this awareness,
or this voice that tells you why,
have to accompany you all the way
through your learning.
It is not just something you start with
and then you forget about
because there will always be moments
where you'll have "set backs"
How is it in Italian...
Luca: You have second thoughts, doubts...
Stefano: Thank you, exactly.
Or let's say moments of difficulty
when you don't know where to go
and this awareness, in my opinion,
that is somewhere in your brain
will help you with new momentum,
to overcome these moments.
The second big factor, personally,
is fun.
I only do things that I like.
It might sound weird, but rarely, I do something
language-related that I don't like doing.
The enjoyment, doing something because you want to,
and not because you have to,
is what allows me to learn more efficiently.
I mean, with the same amount of time
I learn more efficiently
If I do something that amuses me,
for example,
If I speak or read about something that I enjoy,
and that I would read or listen to in Italian too,
not just in the target language
So this is fundamental for me.
Another thing, another golden rule,
is that...
I don't know if you already heard about this,
but "one is more than zero",
One is way more than zero
One not just a little bit more,
is a lot more than zero
Luca: It's your motto.
Stefano: This is my motto, yes.
Meaning that, especially for those who have a family,
is a dad, etc... the time, I can assure you,
time grows short.
As soon as you have five minutes,
you should not think
"oh no, just 5 minutes is not worth it"
instead, yes, it is worth it.
Even just doing one simple thing,
listening or building to a sentence,
making a thought, anything...
Any exposure to the language, is way much better
than not doing anything.
So, even if you just have 5 minutes,
don't procrastinate, but do that something
because that is way more valuable than what it seems.
And... finally, If I may something else
that maybe you also said many times, in many of your videos.
And that is to open the doors of your own life,
to the language that you want to learn.
This means surrounding yourself with tools and
inputs in the foreign language.
Set up your life, so that you almost "have to"
use the language, without noticing it.
Without doing extra efforts for using it.
I'm talking about meetings, apps that allow you
to meet people from all over the world...
you can chat with people in China, in Japan, without any problem.
You can talk on Skype, you can look for a tutor or a
language partner.
You can subscribe to magazines about something
interesting for you,
and that you would use
in your mother tongue anyway.
You can do the same with a foreign language
What I do here, in Brussels, which is a very international city,
is going to shops or cafes, where the owners
or the people that go there
speak the language you're interested in.
You hang out with them and speak that language
Every day even, if you want
Any time you can go to the cafe and talk
for example, in Portuguese
here in the cafe next door
This is the secret
Also for maintaining the languages
not just for learning them
this is fundamental.
At the beginning of this year,
one morning, at midday, I realized I had
already used 8 languages.
It doesn't happen every day,
it is an exception.
But I didn't actively try to use all those languages,
and, not even at 12 pm, I had already spoken
8 languages.
Among which, Georgian, because I found out
that the mother of two kids that go to school
with mine, was Georgian.
So, I even spoke Georgian at the bus station.
Luca: When you use Georgian that the bus station
it means that you won
Stefano: The day could end there!
Luca: Before 12!!
You can go back home happy!
You're great Stefano, as always.
So, as for me, there are some things
that overlap.
You've already said some of them
So I'm going to tell you what I think
You already said the most important one
But I'm going to say it again because is fundamental
is the WHY.
The motivation comes from the why,
knowing why you do something.
Very often, the people that give up
don't know that what usually happens
in any new activity,
is that in the first week you'll have a lot of
enthusiasm...
"I'll do this, I'll do that"
For languages, you start a sport, you go swimming...
Any activity...
And then you drammatically lose motivation and moment
Which is completely natural.
Many books talk about it.
And that's the moment where having
clear ideas make a big difference.
Why do you want to start a new language?
In particular, before starting a new language
I always think about it very well.
There are always these "sirens" calling me
They often ask me "why did you learn this
language, or this other one?"
And I always answer that it's not me
the one who choose the language,
but it is the language that chooses me.
Somehow it leaves hints.
I went for a trip somewhere,
I like the country, I read a literary work
I met an interesting person, I saw a book
that suddenly made me explore this country
You name it...
At that point, it is important to understand
that watching a movie or meeting a person
Is maybe necessary for me, but not enough
for overcoming the obstacles that we will
inevitably meet on our way.
So, knowing the why,
knowing exactly why it is important,
if creates motivation in the long term.
Another important thing for me,
I'm not saying it is generic,
but particularly for me,
I noticed, reflecting on myself,
that it is fundamental for me...
I always consciously visualize,
in the beginning and during
the first months or weeks,
how I will be in the future,
in the next two years
talking and using that language
in the future.
And every single time I sit down
to study a language,
be it Greek, Hungarian, Danish...
I project myself, my mind looks ahead
automatically and says:
"How beautiful it will be speaking
or using this language"
For me, the language "doesn't live
in a vacuum", as native English speakers would put it.
"it doesn't live in a vacuum"
But it's an live entity.
So, as opposed to other polyglots
or language lovers,
I don't...no criticism intended but
I never see a language as something
that I can learn a little bit
If I start it, there is no going back!
It's a life mission.
Learning a language for me is about Integrating it into my life,
to change it, to enrich it.
It's not just about saying simple things such as "Yes" and "hello".
Saying even just a word to a foreigner in his language
fills them with joy.
But for me it is like a mission.
I know that you told me the same
thing yesterday,
we agree on this.
Third thing...
Second thing,
so, let's say, looking ahead
and knowing why,
motivate yourself is fundamental.
Without this, we don't go anywhere.
It is like having a Ferrari without gasoline
You can have the best method in the world but without fuel, you are not going anywhere
The second important thing is to plan.
I mean, I'm quite structured,
as I showed you yesterday.
Maybe even too structured,
I mean excessive.
You don't need to be so structured.
By the way, I'm sorry guys.
There are those green parrots
that make,
Every like 20 seconds there's this sound
Stefano: It's beautiful! Don't worry!
Luca: I hope so!
They are beautiful to look at, but hearing them is something else altogether
After five hours with this chirping..it is a bit too much.
Anyway, the second thing is to plan
It is something I teach to my students:
to distinguish the planning phase from the actual learning phase.
So, if you plan on, say Saturdays and Sundays what you will do during the following week
Then, during the following week, you only have to sit down and make it happen.
I recently read that Steve Jobs
in his biography, I don't remember which one
was famous for always wearing the same clothes.
And he said that the reason for this was
he didn't have to put energy in thinking
what to wear in the morning.
For me, this is very similar
because on Saturday and Sunday
I plan my whole week
So that I don't have to choose
what to do, how and when during the week.
And it is fundamental especially when
you have to manage 14 languages.
So, the more structured you are, the better
if you want to have a certain
"polyglot lifestyle".
So, my suggestion, also for the people
who are not polyglots,
is to structure your day.
Knowing exactly what to do is an extra.
Then you can relax and do what
you think is best.
So, this is another important point,
as far as I'm concerned.
And third, there are many more,
but third is to invest your time
to understand what's the best method
for you for learning a language.
This means that there are some fundamental
principles that are valid for everybody
But the methods are different
and maybe you and I have reached
a good level of “polyglotism”
Let’s call it this way - Jeez, it almost sounds like a disease!
But we have quite different
styles and methods.
which means that you do stuff
that is good for you
And I do things that are good for me
And you must like what you are doing.
Every time that I sit down,
I have so much fun!
Unfortunately, after those 30-45 minutes
I have to go back to my chores
But the reality is that I could stay
the entire day, learning.
Because it so much fun for me.
So, don’t look at a language like something
that you must do and is boring.
We have inherited this from school.
So, school is important
but talking about languages,
you can learn however you want
and having fun,
I can assure you that.
Stefano: Two things, if I can add.
Luca: Of course!
Stefano: Some advice I give
to my students when they say
“I have to study more vocabulary”
“I have to study more the conjunctive”
“I have to study…”
I say: “You have to, or you want to?”
Let’s start saying
“I want to learn Italian better"
"I want to learn Finnish grammar”
And it’s just about mindset
but it gives you a different momentum.
Starting saying “I want to learn this”
instead of “I have to learn this”
You hear that those are two different ways
of putting yourself in front of it.
And the second thing is that there’s
a big difference between the two of us.
I basically never plan anything.
I could use a bad word, but let’s say
that I follow my feelings, my sensations.
But I still have a structure, because,
without it, you’ll go nowhere.
Structure for me is the book
that I start learning with,
that’s the skeleton that allows me
to keep learning
And then I have a limited
number of resources,
like an online vocabulary,
two or three YouTube channels
for the videos,
one podcast that I like for the audio.
But for me planning too much
would be counterproductive,
because of how I am.
I mean, as you said,
there is not a universal way
but everyone has to find their own way.
Luca: It takes all sorts to make a world!
[in English] Ok, guys, we're back.
Sorry, I had to move from the balcony
because the sound was not optimal.
We had beautiful light,
but it was getting in the way
So, we are back and we're gonna continue with
the questions
So, the next one is in German.
Are you still motivated to learn?
If yes, what makes you want
to keep going? And of course, that's
an interesting question. We've already
spoken about that some, but
again, Stefano...
Stefano: Yes, so...
Luca: You can share your opinion.
Stefano: That's a super good question.
I think in my case it's above all
the fun of the language itself.
Maybe that's a bit different
than how you see it, but
for me, the fun is in the language itself
with its characteristics,
unique sounds, the intonation, and
all the structures and possibilities for
expressing oneself, which are
always different, as well as the
connection between the language and
culture of a country, all of that.
And to observe, or experience for oneself,
how all of that comes together
from zero to fluent, and almost becomes second nature.
That's so fascinating to me.
And that's different for each language,
so each language is a new adventure
and that motivates me
to learn more languages.
There's always
something new to discover.
And then, of course, the countless friends I can talk to
when I can finally speak a new language.
But also, for me this is especially important,
during the actual process of learning.
I don't just think "When am I finally going to speak that language fluently",
but instead the learning in
and of itself is fun for me.
Luca: Yep!
Stefano: That makes it simpler.
So yeah, and even during
the process of learning
I look forward to deep
conversations with other people,
to the access to content that wouldn't
be available to me otherwise.
What else...
sometimes there's also a special
feeling of belonging,
so, the joy of being in a group and feel like
part of the group,
that's something very special.
That also motivates me further.
Other than that, yes, of course the fun
and the success that I've had
with language learning up to now,
of course I want to keep going,
and I don't want to stop discovering
new worlds.
Yes, and that's more or less...
Luca: That's everything!
Stefano: ...my answer! And what about you?
Luca: I had a small question for you.
You said that you love
this "grammar stuff",
or the small details in general,
the small details in a language,
and I can imagine that
not everyone loves foreign languages
like you do, right?
But yeah, I thought I love
these small details,
but I have to wonder if
you're actually a "grammar freak",
in English one says
"grammar freak",
and you love the
grammar of a language.
Do you love- do you like, well,
not only the grammar,
but also learning the grammatical
rules every day?
Stefano: Well, not necessarily every day, but
that's definitely part of a language...
Luca: Not every day! But...
yeah, that's a part of the language
that has significance for me.
Luca: That's what-
Stefano: "Grammar enthusiast"! One can say that.
Luca: Okay, that's also a motivation
sometimes, right?
Stefano: Yes.
Luca: In my case...we already said that we're
a little different, that's completely
normal, we have similarities, but there
are also things that we do differently.
In my case, I have to say, the people
that think "Oh, a polyglot, he has to
love grammar!",
in my case, I'm not sure
if that's true, I love grammar,
I know that it's important,
that it plays an important role,
and you certainly have
to learn the grammar
in order to speak a language well, to
express yourself well,
but on the other hand I don't know if I
love it entirely.
What I believe motivates me the most is
the possibility of using a language
sooner or later with native
speakers, right? We already said that,
I can imagine, every time that
I sit down at my desk, I begin to
think, right? About how my life will
be in the future. I don't know, I can
imagine - I did that in German, in
Dutch, or when I learned other
languages - I imagined "Ah okay, I'll be
sitting on a beach, chatting with a girl."
Stefano: Yes, of course!
Luca: Of course, yes! Chatting with a
cute girl in this language, but of course
it's not only about girls, right?
To have interesting conversations about
the culture, the history of a country.
Or to sit at a table with interesting
people and to talk about the traditions
of a country, or not only the traditions,
the culture, the movies, the
books, whatever. It's unbelievable!
And I have experienced so many good and
unbelievable experiences in this
sense, and I'm thankful, so thankful.
And I know what it means to speak a
foreign language well, not only to babble
a little bit, but to be able
to use a language with native speakers.
And I also have to say, in my life, I've
lived in France and Spain, and to know a
language, to speak a language well and
fluently, if you travel to a country and
you definitely have to live in this
country, it's very important to speak a
language. Okay, in Sweden, maybe in
Scandinavia it's a bit different, but
in France, in Spain, in Italy, people
usually say "Oh yeah, you only know
English, if you speak English everything
will be fine."
That's not true. In France, in
Spain, in Italy, and it's not only a
question of communication
"You should speak with the people."
It's that, if you don't speak the
language, everything goes (whistling) -
You don't see the culture, the details of
the culture, it's not the same
experience, right?
Yeah.
And therefore that's what motivates
me the most. For example, Hungarian:
Many people, including some Hungarians, ask me
"Luca, why are you learning Hungarian?
Why? You don't live in Hungary, you don't
have..." for example, many students, I
spoke with my teacher, she told me, many
students are people that are just
originally from Hungary, maybe their
parents were from Hungary, or something
like that, and maybe they want to learn
the original language.
"But you, you're Italian, you don't live
in Hungary!"
And I keep saying
"I can imagine, in the future,
I'm interested in living in Hungary."
I was in Budapest and it was so cool and
I'll definitely use the language
in my life. That motivates me.
All of that motivates me, to use a language
in order to improve myself,
but also in this world, in order to
"live better" in this world,
and live these experiences. That's all.
I spoke too much, sorry!
So, next question here...
I have the list here
is "Daily habits and actions"
I think they wanna know our
daily habits and actions
not necessarily of polyglots
but good language learners
[in Portuguese] and we're going to answer
in Portuguese
Stefano: Ah, we are finally
speaking Portuguese
Luca: we speak European Portuguese
I like it very much...
but well, this doesn't matter but
people generally ask me why I do
European Portuguese
as if it weren't normal to speak it,
OK, what are you gonna do?
Stefano: Alright, so, let's talk about
our habits during normal times
and not during this Corona crisis
because we do not want to talk about that
we want to talk about other things
So let's talk about what I do everyday
in normal times
So, I have a family, I have kids
therefore my life is also father life,
a large part of my life is as a father
so I usually get up at 6.20-6.30
in the morning everyday
Luca: Oh, ok, early
Stefano: Excuse me?
Luca: Early!
Stefano: Yeah, early, pretty early
not as early as you but... [laughter]
and then I prepare breakfast
for the whole family
I also prepare some snacks for the
kids to take to school
then after breakfast I bring them
to the bus stop (European version)
or to the bus stop (Brazilian version)
for all those who speak Brazilian PT
and when I come back home,
at 8 o'clock, my work day starts
I have lessons or I work on other projects
all related to languages
and around 11.30 I usually stop working
and I start studying,
generally the new language
currently that's Georgian, you know
and I try to do at least 30 minutes
it can be reading, grammar,
it can be whatever
After lunch I usually watch
a couple of videos in languages that
I have a hard time finding opportunities
to practise in everyday life
so, such languages will be Chinese,
Japanese, and Romanian too
after that I go back to work
usually until 4 pm
because my kids come back from school,
so... that's it! [laughter]
My working day, the time I have for myself
is over, and from then on
it's 100% father time until bedtime
in the evenings I like to read something,
for some minutes before falling asleep
I am currently reading short stories
in Icelandic, they're really cool
Luca: In what? In Icelandic?
Stefano: Yes, exactly
Luca: Ah, yoiu speak Icelandic as well...
Stefano: That's stories, short stories.
Then I also have books in Japanese, Romanian...
in short, I read something
usually literature, but sometimes
even Georgian grammar. And why is that?
Because Georgian grammar
is great to fall asleep! [laughter]
Luca: For sure!
Stefano: If one day you suffer from
sleeplessness, you can be sure
Georgian grammar is gonna be
your remedy
Luca: Awesome, simply awesome!
Stefano: It's a solution.
So that's my day.
Other than that, I always try to schedule
at least one or two hours of conversation
lessons on Italki
with people from all around the world
in order to practise the languages that
I normally do not use everyday
Luca: Two hours a day???
Stefano: Did I say "a day"? No, no,
a week, a week
Luca: Ah, two hours a week
Stefano: I beg your pardon, no, no,
it's one or two hours a week...
That's all, so what about your day?
Luca: Very well. I get up at 5am,
pretty early :)
Stefano: That's pretty early indeed
Luca: Pretty early but I like it
I like it because I then prepare
breakfast, I medidate
then I write my logbook
it's very important for me to write
for at least 10 minutes a day
to write down what's in my head:
ideas, and stuff
and then for me it's very important
to read a book everyday for 30 minutes
I'm currently reading a book called
"Thinking fast and slow"
I don't know if you've heard of it,
it's very interesting
then I study one language for half an hour
currently I'm learning Hungarian, Greek
and Danish
I can't study 3 languages at the same time
right now because unfortunately
I don't have the time for all 3 everyday
and then I work, I do creative work,
that is writing articles, preparing videos
for my YouTube channel and other things
then I make lunch, and for me it is
important to sleep a bit
an hour in the afternoon, otherwise
it's impossible
at night I only sleep 6-7 hours
but sleeping is very very important for me
and then I give lessons
because I'm a coach
3 or 4 hours a day,
that's a lot of work too
Ah, an important thing to say is that
after lunch I read for 30 minutes
I always read in the mornings, afternoons
and evenings, for 30 minutes each
three different books,
for example, in the morning I read
slightly more difficult books, because
"Thinking fast and slow" you can't read
in the evening, it's too complex
after lunch another book about
self-development
which is a key topic for me:
understanding how to do things
how to organize things
and then in the evenings, I don't know,
stories for example
I am reading a very interesting book
that I had already read a long time ago
in Italian - I'm reading it in Italian -
that's "Sofia's World", maybe you know it
Stefano: I've heard of it
Luca: Very interesting...
it's about the history of philosophy
and as far as languages are concerned
people usually think
ok, a polyglot who speaks many languages
has to learn everyday
the truth is that I don't learn...
I learn one language actively for 30mins
but then, as you were saying earlier,
what makes a difference ist that I speak
lots of languages
because I use lots of languages
I use them for example during the lessons
I have to speak English, Spanish...
Portuguese I use once in 3 months or so
not very often, but in general I speak many
languages everyday because it's the norm
integrating your languages in your life
many people ask me: do you have to study
3 or 4 hours a day?
No, you have to integrate languages
in your life,
then it gets much easier, it's normal...
In countries such as Luxemburg
there are many Portuguese people,
of Portuguese origin, who speak
Portuguese, Letzeburgisch, French at school,
English, German, that's 5 languages
and for them that's perfectly normal,
they speak 5 languages and it's normal
"it's normal in my life" but Italians
for instance do not speak (as many)
because in Italy people speak Italian,
in the US they speak American English
and that's why it's not normal to speak
2-3 languages,
but there is a part of humanity
who routinely speak 3, 4, 5 languages
[in English] Ok, well.
We talked -
we addressed this in Portuguese.
Now, let's talk in -
The next question, we are going to
address it in English.
This is about our job, so
that's interesting!
"How important is mentoring/coaching
in SLA (Second Language Acquisition)
and what are the qualities of a good tutor?"
So, Stefano...
Stefano: Wow! What a question!
That's a broad, broad subject.
Luca: it's a broad question, but it's
an interesting one!
Stefano: First of all I'd like to make clear
what we mean by mentor
and what we mean by tutor
Because I think they are two
different thing,
I think a mentor is like a coach,
it's more of what you do.
Whereas a tutor is more like
language-specific.
Luca: Right!
Stefano: are we talking about the same thing?
Are we on the same page?
Luca: Yeah! But I would say that,
regardless of that,
yes, it's true.
you have to make a distinction
but I think a good language instructor
regardless of mentor, tutor, coach...
Because these are just labels.
What do you think a good
language instructor -
the main features a language instructor
should have, in general?
But then you can distinguish
obviously...
Stefano: I was gonna talk about
how important it is
to have a coach, like a coach
for learning languages in general,
and/or a tutor specifically
for a language.
Luca: Or it is better to have both!
Stefano: Exactly!
Luca: That's what I tell all my students.
As of me, I can direct you and
give you some instructions
then you can actually apply this
with the tutor.
So, why either/or?
It's just this and that!
Stefano: So, I think that if you have
no idea how to start learning a language
and how to organize your self-study
or even if you're under a time pressure
for any reason.
To learn a given language in
a given time you need a coach, I think.
Because you need to be shown how to
organize your self-study
and how to start, basically,
from scratch.
Whereas if you are already comfortable
with self-study
maybe you have some experience
doing that
and you don't have particular pressure
to learn in a given time,
then you may want to have a
language-specific tutor
or, as we just said, both!
And I think that -
But I think that you absolutely need
is other people.
Like, 100% you need someone else
to accompany you
in your language learning process
and journey.
I mean, the golden rule for me is
NO ISOLATION
or, at least, not for a long time.
So, you can look for a coach
to start learning a new language,
if you don't know how to start.
You can look for a tutor for
language-specific questions.
And also you can look for other people
who wanna learn the same language
and can accompany you on this journey.
But talking about what a tutor -
You will probably talk about what a coach
or a mentor needs to have as qualities
But I think I'm gonna talk about
language-specific tutors
because that's what I do.
And I think the number one quality is
flexibility
This is so important!
A good tutor has to meet students
where they're at.
And being flexible means being able
to adjust the way they teach
even though we don't like the word teach,
I know Luca, but let me use this...
I mean, the way they teach, or the way
they help the students learn a language
Depending on the student needs,
preferences, struggles, goals, all these things
It's not as easy as it seems but with
some experience you get to do that
And also, empathy.
Empathy is extremely important because
it allows you to -
to feel in the shoes of your students,
and really almost feel the same struggle,
the same need that the student is feeling.
So that you can better address these needs
Also, I think, experience in self-study.
When the tutor has himself, or herself,
learned a foreign language
or multiple foreign languages, why not.
That's a great thing because you're
pretty sure that they know what it takes
and why is someone struggling with
a certain aspect of a language.
And also, maybe knowing how and when
to correct
that's more important than it seems,
because I think many people
do not understand how important it is
not to correct too much,
not to interrupt students
when they're speaking
and also, to adjust the level of correction
depending on the level of the student.
Obviously, if you're a beginner,
I'm not gonna correct every single thing,
every single mistake, but only the
main ones
because we want to address them and
correct them to improve fast.
But if a student is already advanced,
I'm gonna be much more specific
and correct much more,
even the details.
Especially if I know that the student wants
to speak correctly
and this is among his/her goals.
If not, we just chat, and I just give
an opportunity to express
and use the language,
and practice it.
And that's pretty much it!
Luca: Excellent!
Stefano, you're the man!
[in Italian] Stefano: Look who's talking!
Luca: Look who's talking!
Ok, well... First, as far as I'm concerned
you almost said it all.
I think that the features
that you mentioned
also apply to a coach.
Just one thing that you said,
that's really interesting is
the fact that I always tell my students
that they have to find a tutor
when they start practicing a language
that it would be better if the tutor knows
what kind of feedback,
how to deliver it, and when
it's a combination of these three
factors: what, how, and when.
And this is within the flexibility
feature that you mentioned before
For me, that's number one.
Is that a person is flexible,
whether you're a coach or an instructor
or you're a tutor, or whatever
you want to call it.
Because being flexible means that
if you walk into a conversation,
into a program for a student,
with a set mind that this is gonna apply
to everyone...
Then you're about to fail.
This training is destined to fail
because everyone has different taste,
different background.
So, flexibility in terms of everything
in terms of how you deliver
the feedback,
in terms of how you adjust to the student,
in terms of the goals of the students,
how they speak, how they learn
the language, their taste, you name it...
That's the very first thing.
The second thing is humanity.
For me competence is important;
you have to be competent.
But that's a condition you should ???
So to speak...
But I think that being humane means
being a nice being.
You were using the word empathy
which is a wonderful word.
You have to feel the other,
feel the struggle.
You have to be able to connect
with the student.
That's really important!
And that is for me singlehandedly
the most important thing
And for me, a good coach asks, and
knows how to ask questions.
I believe more and more that
all the answers are in us
and you just need to spur the student
in the right way,
so that they find the answers that
are already in them.
So, I think that a good coach
understands the situation
a good coach has the experience,
understands who they're talking to
and asks the right questions
so that they cause the students
to think about solutions that they can
figure out
and, in this regard, I think that
a good coach is solution-inclined
meaning that they never see problems,
they just see situations that
need to be resolved.
So, if someone comes to me and I have
extensive experience with coaching
so, people come from all walks of life,
you know?
From every country in the world,
I've worked with-
not everybody, but a lot of people!
They come with different problems,
they have different goals and dreams
and struggles.
And you just have to identify the problem.
The more experience you have
the easier it is to categorize
certain aspects or certain problems.
But then what makes the difference
is to ask the right questions.
Like, instead of telling them:
"This is what you need to do"
I can suggest a few things,
but I think it would be best
to just point to a possible solution
and ask them -
direct their brains to figure out
a solution themselves
because, once again, the best answers
are already in you.
You just need to find them!
Stefano: This is fantastic!
This is spectacular!
I liked your third and fourth points.
Very much, very much!
Almost Socratic, I would say.
Almost Socratic!
Luca: I mean, Socrate was a fantastic guy.
You know, the Socratic method,
this famous greek philosopher
who kept asking questions...
He knew that he didn't know anything
but his method was great!
Ask a question, then ask another question
about the question
and then keep digging, and I feel that
keep digging is one of the most
important things we want to do
as human beings, not only for
language learning.
And not only to explore what
method works best to learn a language
but to understand the nature of ourselves.
To understand ourselves, I think it's one
of the first steps towards a happy life.
If you want to put it in
philosophical terms!
Now the last question
of the six languages we share together
and that is the following
and we're gonna reply in beautiful Spanish
What brings the most joy in language learning?
It is a very simple question, beautiful.
[in Spanish] Stefano: very well
Luca: Ok, very well, let's get started.
Stefano: Let's get started,
but you need to help me with Spanish Luca,
Luca: I'll help you, I'll help you
because my Spanish is very very rusty
It has always been this way and forever it will be!
For me, well it has a little bit to do
with what we already said about motivation.
But, one thing that gives me "jewels"
Do you say it like this, "jewels"?
Luca: I would say "that gives me pleasure"
It gives me great pleasure, so that it makes me happy
Stefano: Did you say something?
Luca: No no nothing, continue
Stefano: what gives me pleasure
is the epiphany.
This kind of enlightenment, you know
The fact that something with no meaning
until recently,
all of a sudden changes into
a message you understand
into something with what you can inter..
I don't know how to say it
Luca: "interact"
Stefano: interact, perfect.
This a very special thing, a very special moment
in (language) learning, I think.
And another thing is, well,
the simple fact to express yourself
to have an exchange of ideas, of opinions
with other persons
with whom you probably wouldn't talk
with whom you probably wouldn't have an exchange
if you didn't speak that language.
Luca: Of course.
Stefano: And if not, also the simple fact
of helping others
It gives me great pleasure to help others
Not only as a tutor
not only as someone who helps other people
learning a language, but also when...
I don't know, on the street, in similar situations,
there are people who have a problem
and cannot solve it
because of a lack of a common language
I did it a lot of times here in Brussels
Luca: Me too.
Stefano: at the market and thus
It's also a very special feeling.
And if not, there's another thing,
which is a little bit weird,
and that's when I have a level
which is high or good enough
and I can listen to stand-up comedy
I don't know how to say it in Spanish
Luca: just stand-up comedian, comic comicalness
Stefano: also a special thing is
understand and laugh with a guffaw
and it's a double pleasure,
because there's the pleasure of... the joke?
Do you say it like this? Yes? The joke
Of course, but also to know that
you understood something in another language
because it's a joke in another language
so you have the double pleasure of...
Stefano: The pleasure of the joke
and the linguistic pleasure.
Let's say it like this. And that's it.
Luca: Fantastic, fantastic.
As for me, well, along with all the things
you just said, there are 3 main things
that represent for me an absolute pleasure
when I'm talking a foreign language
The first thing is, just like you,
to communicate with the others.
To talk with other persons, and not only
to talk with the intention to communicate,
but also to talk with natives about traditions,
history, movies, literature
of their culture, of their country.
It is a great intellectual accomplishment
you know, to simply communicate with other people
without resorting to English.
That's already amazing.
Secondly, it was an absolute pleasure for me,
as I already told you before,
that when I went to Spain, Barcelona and France,
knowing how to speak those languages beforehand
knowing those languages beforehand
was an incredible advantage
because moving to another country
is sometimes a little bit stressful
It is stressful because sometimes you need to call
and there's a different system
and you need to make calculations, understand numbers and so on and so forth
and being able to speak the local language makes one's life easier
in an incredible way.
It's a stressful situation and it's a pleasure
being able to do it
and afterwards you're saying "Jesus Christ",
Thank God I speak this language - everything is easier this way!
You can interact with the rest,
with the people,
in stores, you can get your
phone and rent something...
For me, it's a pleasure because it makes
the overall experience becomes much richer
It's incredible.
Third, as you said, talking with natives
brings surprise, a reaction from their side
Sometimes... For example, I'll give you 2 things:
One thing is often on the street
You meet a person who is lost
or a group of people
I remember one, one and a half year ago
when I met a group of Polish people
who didn't know how to get to the Vatican,
who didn't know where to go
and suddenly - because when you're in a group,
you don't have to ask where they come from
because they reveal their language by talking to each other,
you already know it, the guy says something
and you know "ah, it's a Polish man"
and suddenly you start talking in Polish
and they are surprised and go like
"Wow, do you speak Polish? How so?"
Their reaction is an incredible reward in and of itself
I'll tell you a story from two months ago
regarding the pandemic
What happened is that on the 6th or 7th of March,
some days before the (Italian) government decided
to close the borders, there were 2 people
in the grocery store who were asking something
they were trying to... there was a girl and a boy
and they were asking something
I saw it, I saw that they were trying to communicate
in English, but not in good English,
and besides, the people themselves from the grocery store
didn't understand anything,
because they didn't speak English,
and that's why I approached them and I asked
"May I lend a hand?"
and afterwards I asked "What language do you speak
what is your mother tongue?"
and when the girl answered "Hungarian"
and I started to talk in Hungarian,
she was flabbergasted
"Wow, you speak Hungarian!?!"
because you see, one thing is speaking Hungarian in Budapest,
when you're in Hungary, natives will go like
"Ok, you're speak Hungarian, it's something, but no big deal
if you're in Hungary.
But to bump into a guy who speaks Hungarian abroad
all of a sudden... It's their reaction
and besides, they were asking where to buy bus tickets
because everything's closed Sunday night in Rome,
and you can't find bus tickets - like in other countries.
You know, let's put it this way: the overall ticket sale system is way better
in other countries, because (differently from Italy) you can
buy a ticket wherever (and whenever) you want.
That's why I took some tickets in my wallet,
and I gave it to them and therefore
I was a guy who spoke Hungarian,
who gave those two tickets for free,
- because I didn't want any money from them -
and I returned home with a lot more motivation
to learn Hungarian, because the fact that
you could communicate, that you could help somebody
gives you a huge reward, it gives you happiness.
Especially if it's a language like Hungarian,
which is not a common language, you know.
So I returned home with a lot of motivation
and now it makes even more sense to learn Hungarian!
Sometimes you're asking yourself
why am I learning Hungarian?!
and other more exotic languages
and the answer to this question
is right there
Stefano: it's there!
Luca: yes, it's there. And there are always
plenty of possibilities to use the language
that we don't see and suddenly life gives them to us
the possibility to see the meaning of
communication in other languages.
It's incredible, it's a reward in itself.
I wanted to tell this story, because, well, that was a cool story to tell!
[in English] Ok, now.
We share six languages.
But you speak at least a dozen,
and I speak a dozen.
So, we thought about creating
some bonus material
and that's a seventh question.
Now, we're going to address-
I'm gonna address it in a language
that you don't know
and you're going to address it
in a language that I don't know.
And so, if you see me looking
at you but not understanding
it's because I don't understand Finnish.
That's the language you're
gonna speak, right?
Stefano: Right!
The same goes for your language.
Luca: Yes. My language is going
to be Polish, so...
??? of me, I'm gonna listen to
your beautiful Finnish
but I will not understand what you say
Stefano: But please ask the question
in English!
Luca: Right!
That's what I'm gonna do in a second!
So, for those who understand Finnish
that's great!
But, anyway, we'll have the subtitles
in English...
And finally, I will understand
in a little bit what he said.
When the video gets published!
Ok, so, without further ado...
Here is the question.
I'm gonna ask it in English:
"How to squeeze the best out
of your learning session?"
And I think that the person asking
this question-
I don't know whether
they had in mind
your learning session with a tutor
or your learning session in general...
I understood like,
your learning session-
you're sitting down by yourself
and learn, so...
That was my understanding
and this is how we are going
to reply.
please, go ahead with your
beautiful Finnish!
Thank you!
Thank you, Luca
what a joy to speak Finnish
even though you can't understand
well, this is a bit weird [laughter]
So, first of all, it seems to me that
we need consistency and regularity
because you get a good rhythm out of them
and when you have a good rhythm
our brain kinda absorbs
information much better
because it knows: now comes the time
where I'm gonna study my (target) language
and therefore it's ready to absorb more
of what we study
Then, concentration as well...
I'm pretty sure Luca is going to say
the same thing
because I know him
even though he has no clue about what
I'm saying right now
But concentration is very, very important
So, for example, switch off your mobile
or as an alternative,
if your study session is on your phone
you can also use one of those apps
what was its name again?
Was it Peace of Mind? [sorry wrong name!]
Such apps stop all incoming messages
but you can still keep using your phone
so that can be very useful, too.
What else? Yep, write down words,
ideally on paper
but in any case not just words alone,
but also sentences
that is, context is so key
and if you use (apps like) ANKI
there as well you can...
well, it'd be best to write full sentences
because they will give you the context
that you need in order to learn better
and obviously if you are speaking
in your study session
try and use in the new conversation
the expressions you've learnt recently
because that is how they will stick
in your head
by actually using them multiple times
each and every time
Erm, what else...
Well, maybe the most important thing is:
just have fun!
This is so important!
You know, your study session...
... those 30 minutes or 60 minutes
that's your own personal time you get
to spend with the language you like
with the language you love
so be happy, be grateful
for having the opportunity
to sit there and learn it
and just have fun!
That's all :)
Thank you!
Luca: Fantastic! How do you say
"fantastic" in Finnish?
Stefano: "Mahtavaa!"
Luca: "Mahtavaa!"
Ok, now it's my turn
and I am going to speak in Polish
I'm gonna speak Polish now, obviously.
First of all, I think it's very important, if you want to become an efficient learner
first and foremost
you have to plan out everything in detail.
It means that when you plan it out
you will know what things you need to do,
how and when to do them, and that's just great
For instance, I know exactly
which language I'm going to study daily,
how long it will take me,
which method I will apply, etc.
In the case of Polish for instance
I listen to podcasts on a daily basis -
when I take a shower or a bath.
And when it comes to Hungarian
I read interesting articles every day, etc.
And in the case of Greek
I take a conversation class once a week,
for example.
And I study each day,
watch videos on YouTube, etc.
Secondly,
your learning environment
is very important.
It's really, really, really important.
In my opinion, it's crucial, for instance,
that you remove all the elements
that may distract you.
You may find it too obvious
what I'm gonna say,
but please make sure that
your mobile phone is switched off
and your desk is clean and tidy.
Before I introduced those rules
it was a mess.
The same goes for the desktop of your PC.
It's the same thing.
And make sure you leave a maximum of one or two tabs open
which is very important for your concentration
for your attention etc etc
You can even say it's a key factor.
Yes, I can see you understand everything
what I'm saying.
And to my mind the Internet
is a perfect source of information.
But in my humble opinion
also paper plays a significant role here.
That's why I always try and work with paper.
And if you read a printed book or an article
you can take notes on the pages
or underline words and so forth.
And there are other things that you can do.
But in general, I think staying focused
plays an enormous role
We are used to using our mobile phones
but I think you can also get used to
working with paper,
which will boost your learning process.
And remember to study regularly,
it can be as little as 5 or 10 minutes a day
and you will see that you'll know exactly
when, how, and what to do every day.
That's it, that was all.
[in English] That was all!
Stefano (in Polish): Great, great
Luca [in Polish]: very well
Luca: you can say "zajebiscie", "spoko", "mega" (slang words for "cool")
Ok guys, that was it!
I hope you had fun, I hope you
liked the interview!
I found it very nice and always very
informative to talk
with the legendary Stefano.
Stefano: It was a pleasure!
Now, if you want to know more
about Stefano's channel
you can click on the link
in the description box
I've left some info.
And check the video that
we have made together
in these six languages that we share
plus another bonus language
it's gonna be different...
Directly on Stefano's channel.
So, stay tuned and you're in
for a big surprise!
Take care of yourself and
see you soon on YouTube!
Stefano: Bye, ciao!
Luca: Ciao!
Stefano: Ciao, ciao!
Stefano: I gave you the new one,
as soon as I opened, I gave you-
Luca: You Stefano are great!
Stefano: With me...
Take it easy! Don't worry!
Luca: You're immense!
[speaking Polish]
[door bell ring]
There it is! I knew it!
I knew it!
Yes?
I knew that they would buzz right during the interview!
Stefano: how nice it is to listening to you speaking Polish!
Luca: Do you like it?
Stefano: Yes, I do!
Luca: I saw that you were smiling.
Stefano: Yeah, but it's also very weird
doing "mmm, yeah, yeah..."
while I don't understand!